welcome to welcome
the dolls changed thanks for joining us
on this new episode today we chat
with david tackman for the past 15
years david has run his own
news analysis and
political analysis show the david tag man show
this show has over a
million followers  subscribers on the
youtube platform david david was born in
argentina and moved to the united states
at the age of 5 and has created a great
career with his show and it is
truly a super
interesting conversation today for the first time we
delve into the world of politics
We hope you enjoy this
conversation with David Pacman. Let's begin
[Music]
Greetings, welcome to our little
dolls. Today we are going to have a
conversation that is going to be super
interesting and for me super challenging
because I am going to talk to a person who,
although he is young, has  an incredible experience
so that he has a context and he
has a youtube channel
from 15 to  years so she is an expert and
while I feel like a complete newbie
starting all these things today
we are going to talk with david pacman or
david attack man as such david well
thank you very much I am super honored to
have you with you and deivid david I
met him at  through his youtube channel
the famous recommendations of
the youtube algorithm
of videos for you to see and I was always
surprised by his depth, his
professionalism and something incredible and
somewhere I saw that I read that he had an
Argentine nation and I hate it or it doesn't seem like it but
I decided then  ask him a question if he
speaks Spanish and from that initial question
we say then make this recording and
I am super grateful to have the
opportunity to talk with david bachman
david you were born in argentina tell us
about your origins are you your family is they
are migrants who come from europe
we are not over about  You direct please
sure well I was born in Buenos Aires and
my parents too and of my four
grandparents three also who  They were born in
Argentina, a grandfather my maternal grandfather
was from Poland and well in the 20s
I think that 29 or 31 more or less
his family left Poland for Buenos
Aires like many Jewish families in
Europe at that time in the 20th century and
well  That's where my family settled and that's
where I lived when I was 5. In 1989
we came to the US and the
economic situation in Argentina was complicated, to
put it in one way, and Argentina in
recent decades is often a
bad comical situation of
rape.  different imposed political decisions
and of course when I was born
in 1984 it was shortly after the
sui military dictatorship and then, well,
there were many complicated periods
but yes, in 1989 we ended up in
massachusetts in the united states and there it
more or less started again  my life
though and the move occurs because I had
your parents were looking for better
professional work options
that your parents do
if it was bone if they were looking for better
options  professionals but in an
emergency situation but almost an
emergency that is, the economic situation
in Argentina at that time
was very very
so by chance luckily my
dad knew another psychiatrist
my dad is a psychiatrist another
Argentine psychiatrist who worked in Massachusetts
and he  He said, look, I have, you can come to
work, but no, you wouldn't be a doctor in the
US immediately because you have to
make an account again
and at that moment it was seen that
the situation in Buenos Aires was so complicated
that we left
in 1989.
You arrived in the US at  age of 5 years things
like that I imagine it is apart from
adapting to this new culture this
new language must not have been so
difficult because you were still a period
of development of growth
yes sure and there are anecdotes from my
parents for example a few months later  of
having arrived where I refused to
speak English, which is, but my parents
realized that I understood
and they asked me and why?  ul but what's
up why why don't you talk at
school because I didn't tell him it's not that
I'm all waiting to go back to Buenos
Aires no it's not necessary to talk and my
dad told me look we're not going back
to situations like this we're not going to  come back and
from that moment on well
I started talking and it started to normalize a bit
but it is a
difficult situation now I realize
especially now as an adult that it is
much easier at five than at
fifteen in many ways
since  the point of view of the language from
the point of view of understanding and
integrating into the culture but but it did not
have its complexities
and I am surprised that at first I
did not want to speak and you have made a whole
career of communicating and projecting and
speaking incredible right
I didn't think of that in those terms but it
is interesting of course that I could I
could work in fields where talking
is not so important talking to other
people out there would be less important
but it is not an observation  Interesting information,
David, the one you studied,
I studied at the University of
Massachusetts, I studied economics and
communication, and following that, I went
directly to the bank's business school,
and at that time I was a
college and university plan in the Boston area,
and there I studied business.
you had when you chose that career you
had something in mind in something projected
in which you wanted to do with your life did
you choose that thinking about something or was
it sometimes decisions that we make as
teenagers to do it like how
you looked at that moment
well I realized with  Every year in
school I had less interest in
working in traditional fields like
for example in business school
most of my classmates were going to
work in banks or finance that
kind of thing and I realized through a couple
of internships that  He says that I was not
interested, luckily at that
time I had already started my program
during him when I was in my third
year and a few started.  I studied the program in
a very casual way, I
flowered and I had the idea that when I finished my
master's degree in business, try a
year to
do the program in a more professional way,
more like a real job,
Bears, and I decided to do this, I
ask
you, did you say that in a way?  casually we are
talking 15 years ago that now
everyone knows youtube
everyone wants to do something on
youtube or wants to be content but
15 years ago that was like what
I did by chance it's not so
casual were you really eating something  It was
beginning that it did not have much
potential data in a visible way, true for
a person who was perhaps a visionary
and sees it, but as a common thing arises that
they begin to create your program, it
arose very,
very slowly in practice, that is, the
program  15 years ago they had nothing to
do with the program that one sees
now 15 years ago in a program in the basement
of a community station in the north
before massachusetts it was only audi  or it was
once every two weeks so
imagine now it is a program
every day five days a week with video
at that time it was only audio once
every 14 days and over time
as I became more interested it began to do
once a  week we added a
visual component in 2009 and the year 2008
was actually when I had the idea to
add the visual component and that
period of exploring that lasted for seven eight
months after seven eight months we
finally got the cameras the
visual components and it started like  the
next stage of the program and of course from
that moment on youtube in 2009
was something else and of course now with
cell phones and half the
public consuming
video content on cell phones it's already another
world completely and then in the
case  For example, TV so that you can see the
reach of YouTube on that platform, which
I think is the second
most popular search tool for
part of Google, for example.  Last night I
was trying to repair a
ceiling fan and the first thing I do is look on
YouTube and it has become
so involved in our lives that
for example I learned to make a
podcast through videos on YouTube and
it has become  something that is already a
natural part of our daily life
and I ask you initially when you
started in the basement of the
community station the the topics were
similar now we are talking
about policy analysis we are talking
about economics since you were talking in those
beginnings it
was very  Similar to the program now,
of course, I had less experience
and it was
a totally different political moment, that is,
at that time the president was
Woody Car works and I was much younger,
of course, at that time, my
perspective has changed over time and
not  but in a general sense it was a
very similar program at this time of
course it sounds
like george w.bush to me
something that I have talked about something that I thought I have not said
icho and suddenly it is that with the
president that we have suddenly
sometimes we look back at the bus we look at him with a
certain longing like that bus
before the president that we have george w
even with all his limitations it was it was
true he
had much more capacity to let's
say it  So the current president that
we now have
was clearly something else and it is a
conversation that I want to be
careful with because there are times when the program says
things like, for example, when
we think about the year 2012 and the
possibility that he steals or replaces him.  obama
now thinking about it seems so
harmless in a
romney sense compared to what there is now does
not mean that it was a good idea no
so I always want to clarify that I did
not vote for it I did not vote for it but there was a
difference that in 2012 I felt
that for  For example, the four years that
followed economically were going to be more or
less stable regardless of whether he
was brown and Obama president at this
time for me the thing is yes  look very
different very very different much more
dangerous the situation is that over there
we are not leaving yet because that is a
long conversation but I wanted you I wanted you
so I wanted to talk a little about
that program that started as you
mentioned in its branches of a
television station  a community station
has evolved to the point that
you already have
on youtube it's close to 970 mini
subscribers of those like this
and I think you have that if so I say
close to a million because it's a
more interesting number for me but if not
When we started, I noticed that it took us years to
reach 100,000 suites and from that
moment on there was an acceleration and with
good time it is from 900 thousand to a million
they will only have passed if everything continues
well in a month in six weeks or
so when we arrive  a million will
only have been a few months since
reaching 900
and that also has a lot to do with the
political environment of course the level
of interest there is but also  that as
many people as you were saying before
use
youtube like an everyday thing, of
course, live my experience, for example,
sometimes I want to see the content and
I don't want to see so much in analysis, right,
and sometimes it happens to me that I put a station,
for example  they have and I want to see the
news or I want to see what happened
and to be able to accumulate to be able to generate
content for 24 hours of news there is
a little that tells us there a lot of analysis
going away I don't want to see so much
analysis right and so I think that
in  that in that aspect well for example
youtube that has allowed you to be
selective I want to see this specific
I want to go directly to the meat
we are going to talk about the matter and I do not want to
be around looking
around listening to the opinions of many people
now why and not  I know if you allow you to
do that see your select
directly what you want to
see directly and that is that convenience
since I wanted to ask you about this
About 15 years of your project,
right, and like
you throughout these 15 years, you've
grown professionally but you've also
grown personally. They say that
men don't mature as quickly
as women, right, but you've had
a process of maturing  Do you think growing up
knowing the world as how you see yourself
compared to that of 15 years
ago or 5 years ago in a matter
of your maturity of being able to handle so many
things that accompany your
project, your channel, your
good program from a political point of view
which is what is seen the most if someone is a
follower of the program what they see
every day is the political perspective no
so let's talk about it a little first
there is a part of my audience that thinks
that with  time I went to the
right politically it is not true and
indeed every couple of years I use there
are different tests that can be done
on the internet such as power that
camps is one and every couple of  years
when people start to tell me no, no, now
these media outlets are outrageous right-wing media outlets
and I do one of those
backwards every time and I'm more and more to the
left, it's the truth, so that's
from a political point of view but
from the point of view  a more personal view,
well, look, 15 years old when the program started,
I hadn't finished
university and I did
n't live alone at that time, I lived with
my mom at that time, that is, a
lot has happened in my life in the
last 15 years and in some ways around a
A little more subtle is noticeable in everything, that
is, how I manage the company, how
I think about the importance of
vacations and having periods of not
working, for example, 10 years ago it
would be a very different perspective
from the point of view
of friends and family.  In other words, everything has
changed in a sense and at the same time
the program remains the same, in
short, if I ask you about maturity
because I have seen, for example, there is one, there is
a character, there is another, I don't know how to say  leave
commentator political analyst is that if he
reads peterson and you have been
on his program three times and that
you are the way of thinking for the
person who does not put it that you
are completely different both
in philosophy in thoughts  the
things they believe but also in the
way they address them, leave their arguments in a
way that they speak to you and then I
could see that those three
presentations in one of those presentations
he had everything he took you out of the program and
yet when I saw the third  I saw the
way you
are talking with someone that many
people see them as enemies or want to
see them as enemies and talking in a
way we are going to say I don't know whether to say
civilized but in a way that
is mature and that maturity is what I
mean  How can you deal
with talking to people who can I
can I hear it I can think
it's my irrational
fanatic reasons that I can't
attribute it  It is logical thinking and
yet you have the ability to
sit down with those people to talk about
certain topics and that maturity is what
surprises me that you can talk to me about that.
Well, look at that example,
the truth is that it has nothing to do
with maturity  It has to do with the
idea that
when he voted for me it was an interview by
videoconference
and when we got along very well I was
in Los Angeles in his studio yes and it was
a completely different situation and it's a
bit deciding which of the characters each
one is going to clark  to keep in mind not for
each interview but don't look, it's a lot of
people who often ask me
how come when you talk to, for
example,
and a white
extremist Spencer, how come you talk in a
normal way as if he were a normal person
and I always tell them  the same and that is that
starting to shout start shouting
stop the conversation does not benefit
me and it is not good for the public in
practice and it is always possible to assess
the  I'm talking to someone with ideas that are so
different, so opposed, but it's
not a decision, more than any
good thing. Look, if we're going to do this,
let's have a
clear conversation. If I tell you in that regard,
I have to admit that it really
is.  Incredible because I, for example,
when I had that opportunity to
talk
maybe maybe what I say will be controlled
but my facial expressions my gesture
my face that sarcastic face that one does
not use the body sometimes one cannot
hide what  Your body is saying
and has those conversations that are difficult for me,
I am going to listen to people,
that is why in the case of Yesil and Peterson,
when he sees everything, yes, if you are a
week. Consistency, if you are weak or
strong or you are an alpha male.  but no you
are a beta male and it is like an
incredible mentality that I
could not maybe try to reason with a
person obviously true but it is
really and I thank and thank you I read
In particular, I call it maturity because
I appreciate that you have that opportunity
to talk to these people and it's true
that ideas flow without without
the personal part stopping that
particular interview that you mentioned
in Los Angeles with jazz and Petersen
half jokingly at the  At the end of the
interview, I said that I think that this
interview will be of great interest
to sociologists of the future, to
psychologists, and I heard that it was kind of
an insult in one sense, but at the
same time it was true in its way, of
course, it's incredible.  as
part of your job
you are you have been exposed
to criticism from many people I have seen
people who, for example, other people
who have programs similar to yours
accuse you that they have bots
looking to raise their subscriptions and in
this race let's see  who gains more
subscribers there are people who have
accused you of things true of the things I
have heard they have accused you since
accused of  It's true that being an atheist is
an insult and being a neo-Nazi and many
things and then how do you handle
these attacks that are not
well-intentioned to begin with are with the intention
of blurring how you handle that,
well, some are jokes, for
example  Reaching a million
subscribers on YouTube is a joke with
a friend, so that's the medium, since
it's not a different thing, but look, the
truth is that if there are serious threats, he did
n't publicize them and I send them to the
authorities and that has  happened to for that it
has happened then those are not listed
because they are already something else another category
let's say I and insults are not
listed well look at the
beginning 15 years ago 12 years ago when
all this started I was a little afraid to
say what I really thought
Because of this idea that someone is not going to like it,
why and what happens if they send me a
negative or aggressive message,
eventually you get used to it and at this
moment about 3,000 or 4,000 comments come in every day.
r day on our
different platforms and I didn't even read
all of them ok but when I see one and it's
negative I try to say good but
there is also someone who said something
positive the problem is that I think there is
a tendency to pay more attention
to the negative than the  people say sure
then 10
positive comments and 1 negative can appear and it is very easy to
keep thinking about the negative so
that is a general thing I think but
from the point of view of the program over
time because there are more and more comments
every day  days the truth is that I see
less and less as a percentage of what
comes in that obviously you have I imagine
you have a team of people who
help you manage these give you the
comments answer manage social networks
because they have a team is
quite large from a  small team is
a team of four in total
including me and in general my idea
is that the program itself is where
I talk to people about political issues  ethical and in
principle when people send emails
we have something on our website that
says that if you send a
political comment someone is going to read it maybe
it's me maybe not and if it's an
idea for something the program will reach
the place  appropriate but it is impossible
for me to talk about politics by email
with the public
the same on twitter so in
principle the idea is that the team
pays attention to what is coming in and
when there are interesting ideas they are
discussed in the program but basically the discussion  Politics has to be
limited to the program because otherwise it is
impossible, of course, of course, David, it is that you
mentioned, as we mentioned a moment ago, they
were the comments of
people and sometimes, as a matter of fact, they are not
favorable. I want to hear your opinion
on this and it gives me the impression that
suddenly so much gives so much access to
information to a forum social networks
twitter suddenly people and
I think
and obviously my perspective is very different
Unlike yours, you are very appreciative
of your way of thinking, but I think
that people like that suddenly
believe that their opinion about
something is something sacred to the point
that suddenly what is data what
is statistics is not  They are really important
to me, they give me your example, which
has nothing to do with politics, but for
example, thinking that in the year 2020 there will already be
movements of
people who believe that the world that the
planet Earth is flat is incredible,
but then it is  The important thing
is that my opinion is sacred and it's time to
express my opinion even if I forget even if I
don't pay attention to the data
that you think about this phenomenon.
Well, there are two parts. First, there is the
idea of ​​sacred opinions and there is a
term in English.  that it is a sacred cow, it is
believed to be an idea that is
frequently used and my point of view is that
if one is not being offensive just
for the sake of being offensive, they are not purposes to
generate a  This negative environment should not
exist, this idea of ​​ideas that
cannot be questioned, ideas that are sacred,
well, it is better in general that this does not
exist, but at the same time, it is necessary to be
able to establish some facts to be
able to have these conversations in a
logical way, so the problem that
What often comes up is that a lot of
people say there shouldn't be any holy ideas
but we can't come to an agreement
in terms of basic facts
when you can't do that it's
impossible to have a conversation about
opinions and that's effectively how you bring up
the problem  from the flat world to the
flat world that is a
serious problem but there are many others and
especially now with what is
happening with the virus it is very important and
it will do so with real repercussions,
that is, how many people die is a
very very important thing  serious
and without being able to establish basic facts it is
very difficult to create a base of honest discussion of
course of course
you think oh oh there  Some people
may say that trump is
good in Puerto Rico- tenth and we are
telling the truth about our leaders we have
had our political complications
in recent years in our
also economic crisis but we say that
the people have the leaders they
deserve what they expect  choose and
then that in the leaders
that emerge are representing
our people in the case of trump
one could think that it is an anomaly or it
is an increasingly clear manifestation
of what the us is or what it is of
the  of the relevance that a
part of the nation of the usa has taken
on now, as you see it, it is
a very complicated issue. So, to
know where, where it makes the most sense to
start, I am thinking a little, it
is true,
for example, in sand or in the election
November I have already said many times
that if after everything that has happened
after how trump won in
2016 and everything that has happened since that
moment, 15 thousand me  all false
promises impossible promises promises of things
that were never going to happen
and lately the last six months the
management of the coronavirus if after
all this wins again in a sense
the country deserves it I
agree with that idea but it is a  little
complicated because the usa is a very very large country, it
is one of the largest countries in
the world from the point of view of
flower population and there are areas of the country that
would be large countries compared to
europe compared to others in
other parts of the world that are
I completely disagree with everything
that is being done, everything that is
happening and there are mechanisms including
what in English
we call mandarin jerry and also of
course this question of manipulating the
election in other countries or internally with
the fantastic servers or in different
ways
that also  there is a question of good,
but if he officially wins
, he really won, he won for having manipulated
some system, this is a serious question
At the same time, then, to
summarize a bit, I agree that in the
end, if the Y wins again, we
deserve four more years and some of
us are going to have to decide, well,
what do we do? Let's go, yes, if it is possible or
not, not everyone can.  go that it will be
each one but at the same time I am not
very confident that what is
announced on November 3 or 4 will be
the true result of course of course not
even trump has been asked and
he would accept the results  And if he
loses and he has never said that if he
always says that we will see when it
happens, let's wait for the truth, then it is a
dangerous position because suddenly
sometimes one says well, look, the
people are there
and the institutions are there, organizations and institutions are there
to make sure  that the individual, well,
does not fail any mistake of
a person the
democratic institutions are going to cover it in
the case in the case of president trump
as in the case of the service  postcard that
there were a lot of manipulations and
things that you see as worrying is
true and so I wanted you for
a moment the question
seems to me that I wanted to ask you because
there are times when it would be like the
syndrome we are also going to say that is the
example that  I had in mind the
syndrome of the battered woman a
woman abused by her partner
suddenly even defends him and
then it worries me or as you see it
that suddenly I remember before in the case of
Obama for example if one day he dressed
in the suit  of a light color that was
a scandal
but suddenly with the president of
trump there are so many things that worry me
that suddenly common like the example with
dimensions of a battered woman
suddenly we become
insensitive to all the things that he
does and suddenly  Let's get used to
accepting them
when I think it's very
important that we don't let our guard down
or get used
to the things that he constantly does,
golden lies.  with these constants,
of course,
how we evaluate the work and a
president has completely changed in
the last four years and every
week or many more than once a
week there is a scandal and a term
that in English I call
hyper none mobilization that would be  hyper-
normalization, which is a process that
happens to all of us, that is, it happens to me because
I follow this every day, so
I am used to it
every day if there is a scandal
and to the people who follow it in a
more casual way  like 'with people who have
jobs that have nothing to do with
politics but follow politics a bit, they
also start to get used to it and it's
very, very difficult to prevent that, but it's very
important because I almost chose a month of
this presidency, that month contains more
scandals of what Obama had in eight
years but at the same time it is like that
at a human cost we get used very
easily to the current situation and that
is a serious problem since  the point of
view of the election, of course, no, and
for example, there are things that,
once again, from my perspective of the United States,
stands out from Puerto Rico, which is another
story, a
colony for more than 500 years and all that,
my perspective is different, but see for
example  in
things that were not before were deadly
sins,
for example, he left me the name
of the concept now when you place your
family in political positions or
employ them it is the same
nepotism one sees nepotism so
marked in the case of trump then
before that was something common that is very
serious now suddenly that is so normal to
have the whole family and see at the at the
at the convention to see
his future jean his girlfriend talking about his son
and suddenly see that they are
using the house  white to make
speeches to make
naturalization ceremonies as part of the
convention and so there are so many things
that before there are like mortal sins
and now they are like normal and every time it
's like  Every time he expands his
borders, the things
that they do well, an incredible thing,
well, imagine many times talking
with friends, I tell you, imagine if they
counted, it was the president and his daughter at
a convention or meeting of the g20, the g8,
for example, I was sitting in  the table
replacing the secretary of state,
for example,
would be on foxnews 24 hours a day,
talking about nepotism, saying
that she cannot legally be in
that position, which is the worst of the worst
that has happened in US history, it
would be incredible and  it happens every week
every month now there is trump's son-in-law
these days on the first flight
from tel aviv
way and there as a
government official although he was not voted in he was not
confirmed by the senate he is in a
position that is why because  trump
decided that he wants it to be there if it
would be that they changed the whole
conversation in the last four years
and it slipped towards more and more
absurd  over time, but of course in my
case, as I can understand, let's
say it this way, I can understand
that someone has decided to vote for someone
else because he is a Republican and
has all his beliefs and it is true,
we are going to tell his ideology  and
decide to vote like this but
I will give you, for example, a case of some
friends of mine, seeing that they are defenders
of the spinning top president, they are Christian people,
I am religious,
and what surprises me is that, for
example, you want your children to be
honest, that they be honest, not
They lie that they do not mistreat and be bullish
those things, you instill in your children
if you want that or, for example, if you
go to
a car dealer, you are going to buy a
vehicle and if he does, if he does, the seller
seems very strange to you, do not trust him  him and you
leave and then all those things that we
do not want in our lives in beings
that are next to us that we do not
want our children we accept in
the president we are in a
president  that lies
in that a president who has a
long history
of mistreatment of women of
harassment of other worse things is true
and then suddenly I, being a
Christian, can defend the conduct of
something because it may be that I have, it may
be that I defend his ideology  and
its work plan, its government plan, but
the values ​​it represents I don't I
can't understand that and I don't know how you
see it from your perspective
this topic is very interesting because it's
more interesting now because Iovine
is Catholic and we don't have  no doubt
that he is catholic but before arriving in
iovine in 2016
trump had to pose as if he were a
christian character in a sense with he
decided that at the age of 68 after
being in favor of legal abortion all his
life he decided that to the  10 at 68 he
met the son of a friend of his who
told him that at one point she thought
that she wanted to have an abortion and decided not to
have an abortion and trump met this son and she liked him a
lot and that is why  or he changed his position
and now he is against abortion now
for me it is not a very credible story
but it was a story that gave at
least a chance to the
Christian voter to say look he had a
change of heart and now it eventually
took 68 years  but eventually he came
to the appropriate position for example
in an interview famously saying that
the bible is his favorite book is there
with the book that number
6 wrote so the point is that the truth
was always that for many of these
voters particularly
right wing Christian evangelists  It's not so much
what the candidate does, it's more what the
candidate says and trump is a perfect example
of that of course of course duch you think I
ask you do you think that the 8 years of
trump but obama sorry verse that is
not a prediction about eight  years of
trump 28 years of obama have been one
that has had a repressive effect
so serious, for example, that
some US population has felt it, it
has  descended so oppressed during those
eight years that suddenly they have exploded
and have come out into the public light in
a more open way, I don't know why, for
example, the first black president of the United States
for eight years, it's true that there
weren't any major scandals all of a sudden, it
's like  They felt so upset with
the situation that they suddenly decided to
go public. Do you think it happened
that way or how do you see it?
I think so, but being careful
to be specific about what I mean by
saying yes, then let's see, to
begin with, there is a group  from the left in the
usa who argues says that obama
caused trump from the point of view that
being very from the center obama is not without
being from the left he really disappointed
the left of what a
democratic president can be to the point
that many  democrats did not vote in the
year 16 and that allowed trump to win of
course in these three states by
some seventy-seven thousand votes
I do not agree with it  Or now if
I think that having a black president with
an active black father
I don't necessarily believe but
active
a movement that already existed and that
could be part of the explanation of
how he won breaking in year 16 with 100
other factors of course  In such a
tight election,
many things can be what changes.
I don't know who wins, so are you, Dénia, for
example, but I think that
there was and the important thing is that it was not
necessary for it to be Trump, not other
Republican candidates would
have also benefited from  This group that
was activated because there was a
black president for eight years,
of course, of course, from David to me, as I
mentioned to you at the time, now I'm worried
that suddenly more than horn, but
why yes, many many ideas from
horn can have an effect  In the long
term, beyond seeing, for example,
I think we have begun to see
effects, although scientists
do not all agree 100% and there is
no clear explanation.  but the effects of
climate change there are things things that
had been progress
in environmental regulations to
protect certain things for example now
that we hear others saying that the
water that comes out of the shower is not
enough and you cannot bathe
that reminds me of a  episode of zhangzhou
that talked about the shower and css and
so that impact is I'm worried about
the damage that can be done that later
to recover in things such
as in national parks
in natural resources
I'm worried there will be the effect of thunder  that
afterwards it is a damage, let's say perhaps
irreversible or for example it remains with us,
we talk from him about
the postal service that suddenly has
been damaged so much that it is privatized and there is
no going back as you see it in that
good aspect I agree and that is why I think
that  this election is very important very
very important and i would use the word
danger when we are considering
what could happen in the next four
years  Now there are certain things that can
be changed in a more or less short
time, things that trump did with executive orders,
for example, especially those
that are kind of like he directs a
certain department that should not
pay more attention to such a thing or is that what
it is  It can change in a short time
from the point of view of the
environment, yes, every day lost is
a day that goes away, evaporates, cannot be
recovered and doubles the work that will
be necessary when someone who is
good at least accepts the  science
took command and it is in control
so for me that is the most
dangerous part of what is happening
intermediate to this is for example the
issue of the health system
well look we lost four years the system has not been
improved for now trump no  it
made it a lot worse it made it a little bit worse
but hopefully in two years follow iovine and
especially if the democrats win the
senate somewhere in the next two years
you can improve the system again
then  Cess is like a spectrum of
things that can be turned around in a short
time,
lost themes and intermediate things,
flower, look, I remember, the case of
Clinton, I remember that there is not a book that I
had read that talked about people like
Clinton was that he was  an avid reader he
chose a lot he was a very
informed person even to him the memory
that he said he painted in the case of the
er sometimes he would go from the book
to fiction and then he would ask
this scenario that this novel presents
is possible but it was a  person who read a
lot and suddenly when we met
one you mentioned science now
and suddenly the image came to mind
of how if you could put the light through the
vein or something or with the disinfectant they
injected the body and it's like  What
worries me is also the damage to the town
that suddenly science, data,
statistics are not important, yes, yes,
they contradict my beliefs, right, and
there is, for example, that one can be
sick and  you can't believe believe it however you
want no that's a cold flu
whatever but if you go to the doctor the doctor
diagnoses that is the reality that is
what happened true to be able to say whatever
but that is the data that sometimes worries
that the damage in  how
a people or a nation changes its way
of thinking its ways of accepting what
is data what is true and when
we are now in such a
historic and incredible crisis without present
at least in the last 100 years
truth that science  it has to play an
important role to be able to manage we understand
the pressure of the economy the jobs and
all that but suddenly science is
not so important because a
president does not give importance to it I don't know
how I am concerned about the impact on the nation
in the  the children who are growing up
who are being educated worry me that
if this is a cultural problem it is a
problem of the educational system it is a
problem of the media it is a
very complicated problem with many components  There are
different parts of the country and in different parts of the country it is more or
less a problem in one part of another, that is,
there are parts of the country where the problem
can be
and particularly right-wing churches
that say and teach directly that
science is not to be believed in other
parts of the country  It is a more
economic problem where the schools are
poorer so it is not because of evil but it is
because of economic reasons that students are not
learning
how to think about certain types of problems and
that type of thing and there is also the
cultural problem, that is, in the year 2012
It was better, it's just as problematic
now, but in 2012 and 2016 there was more talk in these
terms of the
educational system as a
fundamentally left-wing system that is going
to indoctrinate students and that
causes hostility, not against the
system, then depending on the  moment,
depending on the part of the country, there are
three or four different problems that
come together there that you mention and I don't
know what the solution is  Of course, of course, no, and
again the issue with you, they mention
that you do not know the solution. The issue is that
many times one does not know the solution or
one does not know, but that does not prevent you from
paying attention, from giving time and
mental energy to try to see the
things
no not accept everything as we have great
challenges and we have to face them we
can't say no no that he decides for
me I think that in this program for
now in this podcast we don't talk about
many political things but here we have to
see has entered this this in  this topic
today because I am concerned about the part that
many people as you mentioned
suddenly not normal things like what
are the sciences statistics the
data things that are real suddenly I
don't know are not considered and I think it is
our responsibility as citizens
in  Puerto Rico and in any country be
alert and informed to know and to make
decisions we cannot
give the decision to other people or
that someone tells us how to decide  I
believe that this part of us has the
free will to be able to analyze, to be able to
choose to be able to evaluate, we have to
do it and if you choose to vote for
being a political leader because you believe in
his political platform, well, well,
but I think it is the responsibility of
each citizen  pass the trial and make an
analysis within the truth the greatest
capacity that one has to judge that
I think is very important since your
mission is common in a time that is
dangerous
I agree and the only thing I
would add is that there is a
right-wing political movement  I would say what
you said and nothing more from the point of
view of sight it is the job of each one to
be informed and decide good point yes
but we also have to make sure that
the educational system is working and
working well we have to make sure
that the media  they are working as they
should work and we do not want to stop
only in each one you should inform yourself bye that
is not and I think that is also
important  rtant yes if I don't understand I understand
your point what I want to tell you is that
for example it takes a while of
effort I don't remember who was talking is
that many times when I believe
in not true many times sometimes
we want to do things that
They facilitate the process of our life,
for example, in the part of the
labels, I believe that when a child
grows up, he has the concept, although
this is good, this is bad, this is
the labels to help us learn
to develop, but there comes a time
when  that our lives that the
labels become that you are left to
right liberal progressive
and suddenly the labels become
an easy way to explain things that
are more complicated and then when you
see that they we the
republican party against the
democratic party then the  people say
cool that I choose I choose to be part of
this tribe and that they say the truth that is that
they tell me how to think that they tell me how to
compo  rtar black and although you will see in those
aspects of d
if it is like citizens, it will not release that
responsibility, the truth that we have,
we are responsible and not give up
our mental process to
someone telling me how I should do
things and I think that is my way, my
way of seeing the web,
of course, and it is also important to
understand that there is, that is, it is to be exposed
to the fact that there is a more
detailed and deeper infrastructure to evaluate what
we see in the world and how one can
think about problems and make decisions,
and that is the  Partly, there are times that
from my point of view the
American right prefers not to inform and not
prepare people. It is starting from
when they are children to be able to do that, of
course, of course. Babbitt,
I really appreciate your willingness to
have this conversation because
they had met again through  of
the networks and
I love it, I like your way of not
presenting ideas for the sake of presenting ideas, but
presenting ideas and favoring a mental process.
when one looks, evaluates, observes, sees and
makes decisions that is not true, it is very
important at this moment that
we understand that it is true that we must be
informed about making decisions and not
assigning our responsibility to
other people and I am really grateful
that you have agreed to this opportunity
to talk to me
where you can find people
where they can get on your website
and on your channels
of course the most central and
easiest place is my website which is david
pacman dotcom and of course I have a
channel on youtube you can find me  on
twitter wherever they want I am
everywhere and I thank you very much for the
invitation
and hopefully we can do it again of
course of course david something I want to
mention that people who can see
this program is that I have seen that you
have a for people who are let's say
digital entrepreneurs who want to create
content
you have a membership mechanism
where you generate income  You're within your
own ecosystem, right, you're gone,
there are no people who depend on space
jones,
there are people who depend on
ads on youtube, right, if you can't
talk a little bit about that part, share
educational for anyone who
can get ideas on how to do it.  things in
the networks
on youtube I don't know if sure so the
idea is that my main program which
is one hour a day is free for everyone
and is available to everyone with
some advertising in the program we
put it on youtube there is a podcast all that
and  The idea from the beginning was that
some percentage of our public
surely number one has a few
dollars a month with which they
can support us and number two is interested in
something else something additional on top of
the daily program so
we have this membership system and
effectively  Those who sign up on
our website
can get an
ad-free version of the program and also a free program.
additional every day that we do
for them specifically and with that
we estimate that it is less than 1 percent
of the public that does that
but eventually if the public is
large enough 1% or a
little less begins to add up to
significant amounts to be able to support
a company, then that is the
main income of the company, of course, it is always useful,
we always talk about looking for
different ones without building real ones, and
then in English, looking
for income entry methods for your
digital business that is not just everything,
let's say affiliates or that is not  All
for advertisements, right, that is the
advantage that he promised. I did not want us to
mention it because I think it is a
very good model, an example of a
successful model in the part of generating
digital content on the networks and anyone
who wants to
use your example  Follow a model
that has been successful for you,
yes, and what you have to keep in mind is
that it can take years, for me,
years to  years there were few members each
year they joined but with time
following the effort with time it
began to be something more significant that
enabled us the possibility of
hiring employees and continue growing and
improving what we are doing but it
was with effort and after  Many
years of course, David, super
honored to have talked to you today.
I greatly appreciate you accepting this
invitation and once again I am
your follower on the networks and continue creating
valuable informative content.
Thank you, too, and it was a pleasure
and without further ado we will meet
then  the next episode of they
changed the dolls until the
next
[Music]